on avait qu'est-ce qui vaut kss kss
question parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde c'est 80 mais personne c ils
savent se marier tu arrives le ccff ores
et déjà on vient d'en temps deux
sinistres et de l'écrit en alberta la
distribution de l'aide financière
d'urgence du gouvernement albertain a
commencé on parle de 1250 $ par adulte
et 500 $ par enfant s'agit d'une aide
unique chaque famille reçoit une carte
de débit avec le montant accordé la
croix rouge commencera aussi à la
distribution de 50 des 67 millions
amassés auprès des canadiens
conrad sauvé grands patrons la croix
rouge canadienne est avec nous j'ai le
bon chiffre assez 67 millions que vous
avez amassé tout à fait tout à fait
c'est ça continuer à date ses 67
millions d'âmes assez de dons partout au
canada et à 50 millions expliqué nous
qui vont aller directement dans la poche
des sinistrés en deçà de ce qu'ils ont
reçu du gouvernement albertain temps
qu'en plus de ce que le gouvernement
albertain a annoncé aujourd'hui la croix
rouge annonce un transfert de 50
millions direct financière directe aux
plus de 80000 personnes évacuées il
s'agit de 600 $ par adulte et 300 $ par
enfant
donc pour une famille de une famille de
deux enfants donc ses 1200 $ + 600 $
1800 dollars ce qui est particulier ici
monsieur roy sait que le gouvernement
albertain demandé à la croix-rouge de
deux d'inscrire l'ensemble des personnes
évacuées donc on a l'ensemble de leurs
coordonnées
ce qui est puni qu'ici c'est qu'on
annoncer qu'on va transférer l'argent
directement pour la majorité d'entre eux
directement par transfert électronique
dont qu'ils n'auront pas venez besoin de
venir et vous savez les 80000 personnes
évacuées sont évidemment dans la grande
dans la grande région d'edmundston
calgary on vient voir un tour à tour
parce que les gens se posent encore la
question à conrad sauvé où sont tous ces
gens
soit il allait il ya bien sûr les
refuges je vais vous en parlait dans
quelques secondes des refuges ou vous a
aidé mais il envoie une carte si vous je
crois qu'il y avait qualifié cette carte
là d'ailleurs
bon c'était pas très clair pour les gens
la maison mais on voit une mountain un
peu à droite de votre cas le gros est là
les cercles rouges et la densité de
sinistres inexact c'est tout à fait ça
et vous voyez que les gens aussi son le
son parti un peu partout au canada aussi
avec certaines concentrations à toronto
et à terre-neuve
l'important aussi on parle évidemment
des refuges mais la grande majorité des
personnes évacuées sont chez des amis et
de la famille c'est un effort important
n'y a pas que les dons c'est la
générosité des gens qui les accueillent
et c'est le support donc comment
rejoindre tous ces gens là ben écoute et
une façon efficace c'est de leur
transférer l'argent directement
électroniquement donc c'est ce qu'on a
commencé à faire donc quand les 24 à 48
heures on a va transférer 50 millions de
dollars 650 millions les 600 $ par
adulte et 3 100 par enfant quand vous
additionnez tous à combien vous avez
déjà inscrit vous en envoyer combien
plus de 80000 donc c'est en principe
c'est l'ensemble des personnes évacuées
évidemment il ya un message il y aura
quelques personnes qui auront des
difficultés quant à savoir s'ils auront
une adresse courriel suis un compte de
banque parce que l'envoi leur permet de
transférer directement dans leur compte
de banque
est ce qu'on va faire c'est que ces
personnes là on va les rejoindre
différemment mais le gros des personnes
on va les rejoindre dans les 24 à 48
prochaine sera donc l'appel qu'il a
lancé depuis le tout début de s'inscrire
auprès de la croix rouge parce que vous
le dites la majorité ils sont allés chez
des parents chez des amis sont retournés
en acadie sont retournés au québec à
toronto et c'est quand le britannique
les gens donc se sont inscrits à peu
près tout cela on passe la majorité donc
et encore une fois ce qu'on dit à tout
le monde qu'ils étaient inscrits à la
croix rouge à la fois pour l'aide
gouvernementale parce qu'on le fait pour
le gouvernement de l'alberta où l'aide
la croix-rouge
ne vous inquiétez pas si vous êtes plus
en alberta on va vous rejoindre ouf
certes pour vous apporter cet appui là
mais tout à fait en revanche moins
étonnant et se peut qu'ils aient des
gens qui sont éligibles à l'aide qui se
sont pas inscrits ils doivent nous
doivent communiquer avec nous à ce
moment c'est on vérifiera leur
éligibilité
il ya des gens qui sont moins chanceux
pas de famille pas d'amis
peu importe et qui doivent encore
couchés dans des dans des refuges
à combien il y en a dans cette situation
là est ce qu'on est équipé pour l'heure
amnéville nourriture vêtements etc pour
une longue période de temps
je pense qu'il ya deux ya deux
phénomènes ici vous avez raison dans la
souffrance à edmonton ici douze mille
personnes qui sont passés par le centre
d'exposition et en reste en ce moment
qui réside là encore dans l'est dans
l'élite caen peut-être en trois et cinq
cents donc ça diminue énormément c'est
des personnes qui n'ont pas d'autre
endroit aller c'est très bien gérée par
la ville de moncton ce que la croix
rouge fait dans ces cas là section vient
ou dans un espèce de grand refuge comme
ça les personnes plus vulnérables que ce
soit les femmes enceintes les personnes
âgées on les prend et on les met dans un
hôtel maintenant vous avez raison la
prochaine étape c'est combien de temps
ça doit du racing voilà la période de
transition d'écouté on est on est une
semaine seulement après l'événement un
peu plus d'une semaine donc tabac je
pense que deux grandes nouvelles une
collecte de fonds sans précédent et une
habilité évidemment avec la technologie
aujourd'hui pour la croix-rouge de
remettre une aide directe pour la
majorité des gens dans leur compte de
banque en fait directement et rapidement
nous ayons des plus grands transferts de
notre histoire en fait 50 millions en
quelques jours directement dans le
compte de marques déjà on va remettre le
montant qui a été amassé jusqu'ici 67
millions va quitter là dessus et je vous
demande en terminant là vous allez
prendre le bon 50 millions la suivons
vous en restez y en a déjà des dépenses
et le 17 millions supplémentaires il a
servi à quoi il servira à quoi et
l'autre question plus fondamentale vous
encourager encore les canadiens
faire des dons vous pourriez redonner de
l'argent une autre fois oui en fait tous
les deux c'est une opération c'est
seulement le début d'une opération
on va ramasser évidemment beaucoup plus
d'argent de l'argent qui est déjà donnée
donc les canadiens donnent généreusement
c'est seulement la phase d'urgence d'un
des médias il va avoir une grande phase
de transition on va aider les gens dans
cette phase là aussi ça va être une
phase très coûteuse et elles dont
jumelées aussi du moment fédéral qui va
venir s'ajouter pour les dons
individuels
donc c'est si les besoins sont en très
grand l'annoncé aujourd'hui c'est
simplement d'aider les gens qui sont
toutes essaie de leur donner une aide
immédiate pu naître directeur pour
qu'ils puissent faire les bons choix
pour se soutenir dans les semaines qui
viennent mais on revient avec les phases
subséquentes bientôt donc vous n'avez
pas trop d'argent là non ne pas trop
d'argent
la reconstruction
l'ensemble de l'effort ici va coûter des
milliards et on sait pas c'est pas
toujours à quel moment les gens pourront
retourner à formerie donc une phase de
transition et portant tous ici la plus
grande opération canadienne dans
laquelle la croix rouge a été impliqué
c'est une des plus grandes en fait 4 au
regard de l'histoire c'est chiant de
l'udps est grande aussi un mais c'est
intéressant c'est très grand et comme je
vous dis je pense qu'on est dans une
période intéressante où on est on est
une habilité à ramasser grâce à la
technologie mais aussi vous avez vu la
carte en fait on connaît on sait où sont
les gens aussi de façon assez précise et
on va pouvoir les rejoindre de façon
directe on va pouvoir s'adresser aux
plus vulnérables d'entre eux de façon
plus directe aussi la technologie qui
change tout effectivement qu'on va te
gré.merci on se reparlera bien sûr mais
si nous avoir donné accordé cette
entrevue je rappelle jacques à edmonton
donc au coeur de cette opération
gigantesque
merci merci monsieur roy à voir